Alon Halevy, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm doing great. How are you?
How have you been during these crazy time?
You know, it's been a difficult
and very challenging time,
but, I'm trying to make the most of it.
So, I've learned how to cook
out of sheer need.
And my cooking skills
have just skyrocketed to a point
where you can actually eat my food.
I've done gardening.
I've been exercising.
So, if you look, I'm actually,
mentally in pretty good shape.
That's pretty fantastic.
I think, it's always fascinating for me
to see how every person
interacts differently.
I was just talking about it
with our family recently
about how it's crazy how we all have this
collective crisis and every person now
manages it differently.
But Alon, one thing that is different
from your daily life is that
you are a big traveler.
And you actually traveled
to 30 different countries,
writing a book about coffee.
Now, for context, you're also a director
within Facebook AI.
Yet, you go and you are writing a book
about coffee. What is that all about?
Well, so, good question.
So, the book was actually written
when I was working for Google.
Okay.
Google gets the credit for the book,
Google gets the credit.
And I think, I have no good explanation
for why I decided at some point in my 40s
that I need to write a book about coffee.
I always like to go to cafes.
I always like the vibe in cafes.
And I always noticed that
in different countries you go,
you get different experiences in cafes.
And so, I was very curious
about trying to map that
and studied it at a little more detail,
why am I getting these
different experiences.
And then, I did something which ultimately
led to writing the book.
I started telling my friends that I think,
I should write a book about coffee.
And after a few months,
my friends have start coming back to me
and say, "Hey, where's the book?"
And once you sign a social contract,
you have no choice but to do it.
Alon, I love it so much.
I created a Google map.
And I listed through three different
countries that one must visit
in order to write a book about coffee.
Many of them I was travelling to,
or to the area anyway,
because of the nature of my job.
Right.
Some of them, I actually,
had to take a few days off.
That's hilarious.
ALon, how many cups do you drink a day?
Just for context.
Only two. But they're very high quality.
Only two.
If I'm at a coffee conference,
which A, these things exist;
and B,
The coffee conference.
That must be one hell of an energy
in that auditorium.
Yes.
And when I would drink somewhere
between 10 and 15 espressos, or something.
Okay. And before we move on
to technology and high tech,
what is your favorite coffee
you've ever tried in your life?
The country and place.
The favorite is from a region
called the Yirgacheffe in Ethiopia.
It came from a one the cooperative there.
It just blew my mind.
That's a thing. Great coffee,
will just blow your mind.
One of the hardest transitions I've had
coming from Tel Aviv to Palo Alto,
I have to admit, is getting used to
not having my afuch in the morning,
and my cappuccino.
So, that was definitely a big change.
But Alon, we only have 15 minutes left.
I have wasted way too much about coffee.
Take me through your journey.
You start out as an entrepreneur.
Move on to researcher.
Go through these incredible companies,
like Google, now Facebook, Bell Labs.
Why are you so curious
about your domain expertise?
You're also professor
at University of Washington.
Walk me through your journey a little bit.
Okay. So, I had no doubt in life
that I needed to be a professor.
Really?
My father was a professor.
It looked like the right job to do.
So, I never actually
had a point in my life
where I had a hard decision to make.
Interesting.
So, it's obvious
that I wanted to do a PhD.
At Stanford, of course.
I came to Stanford, of course.
And then, after I finished my PhD,
nobody gave me a professor job.
So, I went to, what was at the time
a pretty prestigious lab
called AT&T Bell Labs.
And a few years later,
I got an offer to be a professor
at the University of Washington.
Wow.
Then I realized that,
this is within the height of the 90s
when all these startups were going on.
Is this where you actually met my father
back in Bell Labs?
In Bell Labs, yes.
Okay. Okay.
Now, I'm making the connection.
Yeah. Yeah.
Your father and I, were both part
of the database community,
the academic database.
So, I've known him since I graduated,
maybe even before.
Wonderful.
So, first of all, did that professorship
live up to your expectations?
Why did you want to be a professor?
I mean, obviously, yeah,
your father was a professor,
but what attracted you to academia so much
as you're seeing the dot-com rise,
and obviously with the bubble,
but everything rise?
I think, at my very core,
I like to think about new ideas,
break new ground,
and ask the questions that will lead
other researchers and engineers
and companies to think about
the next generation of products.
So, to do that, being a professor
is a good place to do that.
I really enjoyed working with students.
I had some pretty awesome students
at the University of Washington.
And I would still recommended it.
I mean, being a professor is
what you can do must worth.
I also have a entrepreneurial bone
in my body.
Yeah. So, take me through
your two companies.
The second one was acquired by Google,
I believe. Right?
That's when you joined Google?
Yes. So, the second company
was based on a project that we did
at the University of Washington.
We developed some technology
that enabled search engines
to actually crawl beyond forms
on web pages.
So, if you saw a form until then,
you needed a human
to actually fill in fields of the form
and to get all the content.
We developed a method
that was able to do that automatically,
and therefore, add many more
high quality pages
to the Google index at the time.
And we're actually still looking back
at 2005, 2006. Right?
These are around the time.
So, it's still very early.
And very few people
talked about web development
and websites just became a thing.
That is true. That is true.
It's now that I think back at it,
that's a good point.
We still didn't understand,
web search were still,
even though Google was already
a public company when I joined it,
web search was still in its infancy.
And it was a really,
I remember at the time, Google was
an extremely exciting place to be at.
I have a group of people who are coming,
I just had a very fascinating chat
with Marcel Kornacker from Apache Impala.
And he mentioned that he was at Google
also in around 2003, 2004,
working on databases,
and how exciting it was at the time
when it was just people
are understanding what's the potential.
Along, give me your two cents quickly
about this intersection between
academia and startups.
You're working on a research
as a part of academia
which naturally flows
into the high tech scene.
You've formed a company out of your work
in the University of Washington.
Stanford professors are very well known
to do this type of thing.
Andrew Ng, I believe, runs about 10 or 11
different startups at the same time.
So, what is this?
Is there a dissonance?
Do they want you to do this?
Is this [--]
So, that is something that has,
over the years,
the universities realize that
this is a good thing for them, right?
So, if you go back even 20, 25 years,
it was a difficult thing to do.
Universities like Stanford and MIT,
realized early on that
being part of that ecosystem
is an important thing for the industry
to be involved in.
And then you get a bunch of lawyers
in the room, right?
And so, it takes a while
to work out the process
and to make sure that everybody
is, has right credit.
The university gets a cut,
the students that were involved get a cut.
Whatever. All these things worked out.
And also, universities were letting
faculty leave for a year or two
to work on their company
and then come back.
Which is really important.
Because it's very hard
to start a successful company
and not be full time at the company,
especially if you're the founder.
So, I think today is very different
than what it was when,
like 15 or 20 years ago.
I think today, it's taken for granted
that people are going to do this.
And I think, the process
is much more well established.
But again, it varies by university
and country.
And it's not easy everywhere.
All right. Okay.
So, I'd like to fast forward
to present day.
You're a director within
the Facebook AI group.
And everybody talks about AI.
And especially now as we're approaching,
2020 is a monumental year.
And not just because covid,
which is a very data driven pandemic.
I mean, the whole world
is trying to figure out
what the hell is happening.
But also we have elections coming up
and you have,
data is just playing such a more
significant role in our lives.
More and more.
And that's something
that I'm very curious about
within Stanford.
At the level of a director,
with your experience in the field
and with the responsibilities
that you hold,
talk to me a little bit about
why you're passionate about
the field of artificial intelligence.
And maybe, a little bit about
our responsibility as we develop
responsible and ethical AI.
Wonderful topic.
I'm totally into that right now.
So, the short answer is
there's never been a time in history
where AI was so crucial to the continuing
functional behavior of humanity.
Okay?
So, let me be very specific.
Social networks are awesome, right?
They enable anybody anybody
to have a voice, right?
They enable, whether it's a famous person
or your next door neighbor.
Anybody can say anything.
You can start connecting with people
in other parts of the world
that share common interests
that you never met before.
Wonderful social value
that you network with.
No argument there. Yeah.
But, and there's always a but
when there's a great technology, right?
Social networks also are a window
into the worst in humanity.
Whether it is people
putting up hate speech.
People creating
and disseminating misinformation.
People exploiting other people
for various, there are things
that I don't even have to mention.
People try and sell illegal items
on social networks.
So, the number,
and we call these violations,
these are policy violations.
But I think, the big thing here
is that we're talking about scale.
So, you can have a thousand people
sitting around and reading every post,
but when you get to millions
or billions of posts a day, at that scale,
it becomes a feat, right?
Yes. And so, this problem
is known as the problem
of preserving integrity with networks.
Okay?
And hopefully, in a few weeks from now,
there will be a survey
that a bunch colleagues and I, at Facebook
will have finished writing
about this topic that I recommend to them.
So, we're releasing this video
after that survey is published
so that I can put the link there.
because I'm sure, it'll be fascinating.
Sounds good.
Though, this might take a while
because it needs to be released.
Oh, we have time.
Covid Is here to stay for a long time.
Don't worry. This show is gonna go on.
Okay. Good.
So, it is crucial to social networks
to keep the content on the network
safe for the users, okay?
And as you pointed out,
doing this manually is impossible.
Right.
So, what we have is,
we have a bunch of AIs systems
that are constantly looking
at content coming in. Okay?
When these AI systems
are extremely confident
that this content is violating,
they will remove it automatically.
When they are not confident,
or when they will receive a user flag,
so, the users will see content and say,
"Hey, this is what you should do."
We will send it to a large number
of paid workers who will look at it
and see whether it violates our policies.
By the way, in terms of the ripeness
of the technology and of course,
if I ever ask something
that is not suitable for you,
let me know.
But in terms of ripeness
of the technology,
where are we at now?
Is it more so on the automatic flagging?
Or, more so on the on the user flagging?
So, Facebook actually publishes
every six months a report on the numbers.
Okay. Okay.
So, actually some of these,
and there are like tens
of different violations.
I should say, coming up with policies
for what is allowed
and what is not allowed on social network,
That by itself is,
I'm not going to talk about that
because that's going to get me
on a rathole
that I am not authorized to go down, okay?
But you can imagine, right?
This is a really really hard part.
It's based on culture.
Yeah. That's exactly the problem.
The classic problem. Yeah.
Yes. And because, fundamentally,
what you're trying to do
is you're trying to balance
between safety of your users
and giving people a voice.
Yes. Yes.
Very small nuances.
For example, you are not allowed
to advertise, to sell guns on Facebook.
That's part of the policy.
But if you're a gun retailer,
you're allowed to talk
about what's available in your store.
It's, those nuances are crazy.
But Alon, I do want to save some time also
for thinking a little bit broader
about the world of AI
and where we're headed as a society.
So, yes, you've got to see
both Google and Facebook.
And while that's your domain expertise now,
I want to extrapolate with you
a little bit about,  what are my kids
going to experience in terms
of their online behavior?
Where do you see AI integrating
into our online environment
as the years develop?
Because we'll get over our current comps,
we'll get over the elections
and covid and everything.
I want to know
what my kids going to expect
in terms of their integrations.
That's a great question.
So, let's put the integrity problem
in perspective first, okay?
So, 30 years ago,
we had a huge problem with spam.
Just e-mail spam.
We don't really talk
about e-mail spam anymore, right?
So, we solve this problem.
The hope is, that all these
integrity violations,
all this hate speech and misinformation,
it will be the way of the past, like spam.
It's a much much harder problem
in terms of AI, and as you point out,
the subtleties that are involved.
But the hope is, that it'll be like spam.
So, now the question is, I think of it,
so, to me, integrity is,
you come onto a social network,
if you see something
that violates the policies,
that's a negative experience for you.
Okay?
Our goal is to minimize
the number of negative experiences
that you might have on social network.
Right.
Now, let's look at the happy side.
How can we increase or maximize
the number of positive experiences
that you have, okay?
And that's really
where the opportunity lies.
Okay?
How is it, and I'm speaking here
not authorized by Facebook,
this is just me.
I am asking Alon Halevy. Of course.
How do I make it such,
that a social network or any AI tool
just helps me be my best self
any given point in the day. Okay?
So, now if I have a couple of hours free
and I'm not sure what to do,
the computer knows what the weather is.
And it knows what's open.
It knows what I've enjoyed doing
in the past. Maybe something
what I haven't done for a while.
What I'm on is, an AI system
that knows me so well,
but it's very private, right?
So, we're not compromising on privacy.
I want an AI system
that will give me advice
at any given point in the day,
that enable me to be the best,
to have the best experiences that I can.
And by the way, I think privacy
is such an interesting issue.
And I say that because
I'm on the extreme end
of I want everyone to know
everything about me.
I want them to know where I live,
what I do, where I work,
when I sleep, when I brush my teeth.
I want to have the most
personalized experience in the world.
A lot of my friends,
like my age and older,
are very conservative.
Like we don't want anybody to know.
We're very scared yet.
So, we want to enjoy personalization,
but not at the expense of privacy.
I'm saying to my friends
that are younger than me now at Stanford,
because most them are younger than me,
and a lot of the people
in Israel, privacy,
I feel like the generation is like,
I am like  the needle that's about to move
into the realm of we want personalization.
We understand that in order to get
real personalization,
we have to compromise
a little bit of privacy
and we're all for it.
So, I'm a big advocate of that.
Good. And in that case,
I would encourage you
to talk to your friends
and tell them to run for office
and be elected to very spot
But responsibly. Because it has to be done
responsibly, obviously.
It needs to be done responsibly.
And obviously fairness and biosis
and data, because at the end of the day,
we're susceptible to a variety of biosis
in our audience as well.
And this is a field that we're
actively trying to figure out right now.
What are you most passionate about?
What excites you most
in your professional career?
Having technology help people
in their day to day lives.
Like you're seeing the real impact.
Yes. So, I want something
that actually makes the difference.
That either reduces friction for me
or, makes my life better in some way.
That also, what I like to work on.
So, but then, at the end,
you're working within companies
that processes takes time,
yet when you do get
to accomplish something,
they were at billions of users.
So, do you prefer working for a long time
to get to that billion user?
Or, do you prefer the more startup life
where every single day
you're making a positive impact
on the product, on the team?
It's not this or that.
I think, even when you're working
at a company like Google or Facebook,
to get to that billion users,
you're still working with a small team
and you're still working with people
and mentoring people and taking people.
Solving hard problems every day,
seeing people develop
as they mature in your careers.
So, there's a lot of that going on.
And at the same time, publishing papers
that have impact on academe.
[--]
I think without that mix,
I would be not be very happy.
And I think that's also
very interesting collaboration
between the research part of you,
but the products part of you,
which is not always,
it doesn't always go hand-in-hand.
Both, proper researcher
or a professor in computer science,
at the same time,
thinking about the end user
and how your products
impact humanity at the end.
Alon, before we leave,
I want to thank you again
for your generous time.
Really, toda raba.
And I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Thinks outside the box.
It sounds like that's a little bit
of what it takes
to be a director within Facebook AI.
Alon, thank you very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
You, too.
I'll see you around J-Ventures.
I even forget to talk about that,
but I'll see you around.
Okay. Cool.
Take care. Bye bye.